hoy día quería conversar con una
pregunta
ustedes saben lo que significa usar un
basurero
saben el impacto que tiene usar un
basurero todos los días en sus casas lo
cierto es que para una región como la
nuestra
usar un basurero ha significado que casi
la mitad de las comunes que la componen
tengan su parte los cerrados y que la
otra mitad de las comunas que la
componen tengan vertederos con 1 o 2
años de vida útil
como muchos de ustedes yo no sabía esta
realidad hace dos años encontraba
prácticamente quebrado había fracasado
con mi primer emprendimiento y está bien
que volviera a vivir en la casa de mis
padres estaba en ese proceso cuando mi
hermano roberto me invita a participar
de su incipiente empresa y gestión de
residuos una empresa que básicamente lo
que hacía era evitar que la basura
terminara los vertederos pero que
terminara en las plantas de reciclaje
yo acepté el desafío y como no sabía
mucho del tema del problema que es que
estábamos intentando resolver y tampoco
de la solución que estamos proponiendo
me puse a investigar
uno de los datos más relevantes que
encontré fue que en chile todos los años
500 millones de envases de vidrio se van
a los vertederos
y si los ponemos uno al lado del otro
podríamos dar tres vueltas al mundo tres
vueltas al mundo
pero lo más curioso esto es que tiene
una solución bien sencilla
y es que si cada chileno reciclar o
reutilizar
tres envases de vidrio al mes no habría
ningún envase en nuestros vertederos
ahora con el tema la realidad local de
nuestros vertederos con esta solución
podemos reciclar el vidrio en la región
la verdad es que sí pero tenemos tres
problemas el primero de ellos es que las
plantas de reciclaje de vidrio se
encuentran en santiago a 700 kilómetros
de nuestra región por lo cual enviar o
enviar en los recibos hacia santiago
tiene un alto costo monetario digamos
por suerte con roberto venimos de una
familia dedicada al transporte y pudimos
grabar una ruta de bajo costo hacia
santiago
el segundo problema es que necesitamos
infraestructura
en su estructura me refiero a
contenedores donde poder depositar estas
botellas tuvimos la suerte hace un año
de poder conocer a los encargados de la
causa ciudadana elige vidrio en conjunto
con la municipalidad de pucón y colorida
inacap logramos formar un modelo que
permita la instalación de 120
contenedores en temuco
nosotros pudimos modelar y predecir lo
activar y validar este este modelo y lo
podemos replicar tanto en villarrica
como en pucón lo cierto también es que
queremos que más como una se sumen a
este modelo en el corto plazo
por otra parte también hay más empresas
instituciones que se dedican a esto la
municipalidad de temuco va a instalar
puntos móviles en el mismo temuco la
serie medioambiente está a cargo de la
construcción de 11 puntos limpios en
diferentes comunas en diferentes comunas
de la región y también está el destaca
la destacada labor de los recicladores
de base que todos los días recorren las
calles de las comunas de
de la región haciendo un trabajo muy
noble y evitando que residuos como el
vidrio terminen en vertederos y que sean
reciclados
pero hay un tercer problema
el problema tiene que ver con nosotros
ya tenemos el traslado del virus a
santiago tenemos donde captarlo acá en
la región pero resulta que en chile
solamente el 17 por ciento de las
personas reciclan
entonces no sacamos nada con tener una
tremenda infraestructura muchos
contenedores la ruta armada si es que
nosotros no cambiamos en nuestras casas
la forma que tenemos de disponer la
basura
si bien es cierto que tres envases de
vidrio no son la solución completa al
problema de los vertederos si ayuda
mucho a poder liberar su carga porque lo
cierto también es que se nos está
acabando el espacio y en ninguno de
nosotros que está aquí nos gustaría
tener un vertedero al lado de nuestras
casas
por eso reciclar es tan importante ahora
podemos reutilizar o reciclar tres
envases de vidrio al mes es la región
si podemos hacerlo pero esta pregunta
para ustedes en sus casas ustedes pueden
dejar de usar el basurero y comenzar a
reutilizar o reciclar tres envases de
vidrio al mes muchas gracias
[Aplausos]